what's up everyone
so a lot of hype around Avengers for
right now obviously there's tons of
leaked photos
there's leaked videos there's leaked
plots so tons of leaked stuff and just a
lot of questions around what it's really
going to be about but today we're going
to look past that and talk about phase
four of the MCU and yes I realized Kevin
Feige came out and basically said that
they're pretty much done with the phases
but we're just gonna call it phase 4 for
now also the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway still continues if you would
like to enter for your chance to win a
copy all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so there are a lot of
movies that we know about coming in
phase 4 with spider-man far from home
kicking it off but the Disney Foxx
acquisition is done Disney now has the
rights to use mutants in their films so
now the question is how will they
introduce mutants and the x-men and who
will the first one be right off the bat
I don't think it's going to be Wolverine
it's very likely that Kevin Feige
president of Marvel Studios will take
the x-men in a different direction than
the previous x-men films over at Fox and
if Wolverine was introduced there is no
guarantee that Hugh Jackman is going to
be playing Wolverine so it would be
really hard to make Wolverine that first
x-men introduced into the MCU because
Hugh Jackman has already done such a
great job he is an iconic Wolverine so
introducing Wolverine as the first x-men
in the MCU would be extremely harsh
because everyone would just
automatically compare him to Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine I actually think
that the best way to introduce an x-men
slash mutant into the MCU is to do it in
black panther 2 and if you follow the
comics you already know who I think
should be the first x-men introduced
into the MCU and that is storm so why
black panther 2 and why storm well
because in the comics they get married
not only that but they also become
members of the Fantastic Four at one
point so another way to introduce them
black panther or two Charlie
and storm or Ororo have known each other
since they were very young
T'Challa rescued Ororo and they caught
immediate feelings for each other
eventually years later Black Panther
would go on to ask storm to marry him
and what she said yes they had a huge
wedding in which most of the Avengers
and the x-men showed up it was so big
that even The Watcher showed up
unfortunately their marriage didn't last
in The Avengers vs. x-men event the
Phoenix force returned to Earth once it
returned to Earth it began to possess
many people including nan more nan more
ended up leading his Atlantean people
into battle against what Conda this was
a huge event and the fallout from this
event was very severe and brutal
well Condit was basically destroyed the
damage to Wakanda was severe and he
blamed storm for siding with the x-men
this event caused T'Challa to annul
their marriage after this event many
people around the world millions of
people started to exhibit mutant powers
so this is how it happened in the comics
and there is certainly a lot of material
for Marvel to grab here to use in a
movie introducing storm in black panther
q I think would be relatively easy I
know that Nakia is his love interest
right now but you could introduce storm
as his ex-wife and another opportunity
here is again after this event where
what Conda was essentially destroyed
millions of people began to exhibit
mutant abilities so obviously in a
vendor sport there's going to be a huge
battle it's most likely that what Conda
will be used again perhaps it gets
destroyed in this battle and perhaps at
the end of Avengers 4 they figure out a
way to destroy the Infinity stones and
in destroying the Infinity stones people
start to exhibit mutant abilities this
is just one of the many ways that Marvel
could do it but to me since Black
Panther was such a huge success black
panther 2 is a perfect opportunity to
introduce mutants and the x-men to the
MCU these are just my thoughts I know
there are many ways to introduce the
x-men and mutants to the MCU so let me
know what you think about this and let
me know how you would like them to be
introduced into the MCU and again the
giveaway continues if you'd like to
enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]
you